on attendait un rebondissement
aujourd'hui dans la sphère grégory si le
petit garçon assassiné au mois d'octobre
dans les vosges la jeune muriel la des
principaux témoins étaient confrontés
aujourd'hui avec les gendarmes devant
lesquels elle avait dans un premier
temps accusé son beau frère bernard
laroche
avant de se rétracter et bien muriel en
est resté à sa deuxième version celle
qui innocentent son beau-frère quant aux
gendarmes ils restent maîtres de
l'enquète gérard façon les gendarmes au
palais de justice depuis que la chambre
d'accusation a annulé les premières
expertises en écriture
il devient urgent de confronter muriel
aux gendarmes qui le 2 novembre
recueillir son témoignage accablant pour
bernard laroche
cet après midi l'attitude de la famille
de muriel signifiait bien que pour eux
seuls devrait compter les rétractations
qui ont immédiatement suivi
l'incarcération de la roche durant les
quatre heures d'audition un autre groupe
à quelques mètres la famille du père de
grégory
venue elle dans le seul espoir
d'apprendre que l'anc est enfin évoluer
quant à la femme de bernard laroche et
l'entrée et sortie du palais de justice
muré dans son silence les gendarmes des
vosges colonel en tête sont sortis les
premiers chacun d'entre eux venaient
d'être confronté devant le juge lambert
à 7 le petit jeune fille rousse de 15
ans sur laquelle repose l'essentiel du
dossier d'instruction
une petite jeune fille vit depuis c'est
ce ténébreux enquête depuis presque
trois mois ne fréquente plus sa classe
de 3e de transition une petite jeune
fille qui aujourd'hui n'a pas craqué
soutenant que non elle n'a pas
accompagné bernard laroche sur le chemin
d'un crime le 16 octobre dernier dans la
vallée de la vologne
muriel confrontés aujourd'hui
successivement à sept gendarmes a
confirmé par ses propos l'innocence
clamé par bernard laroche depuis trois
mois deuxièmement il semble que l'un des
gendarmes entendu aujourd'hui a reconnu
être l'auteur d'un des croquis qui avait
été produit semble-t-il comme émanant de
la main de muriel de son côté le juge
lambert n'évoquez pas ce point litigieux
il semble que pour lui l'accusation d'
usage de fouet de subornation de témoins
par les gendarmes ne tiennent pas
confrontation d'aujourd'hui en attendant
l'avis de la chambre d'accusation et les
résultats des nouveaux examens
d'écriture reste aux avocats de bernard
laroche un autre argument le
chronométrage des faits reprochés à leur
client apparaît irréaliste
pendant ce temps à lépanges une maison
demeure fermée les parents de grégory
ont quitté les lieux avant noël